it was right here that Anastasio massive
le was shot by five gunmen last week he
died shortly afterwards in hospital who
was an observer in Mozambique selection
and the director of a rights group his
colleague Fernando Yan Toby told us he'd
been within minutes before at a training
session for local observers and shy-shy
the capital of Gaza province
he says Anastasio is killing sent a
clear message from fragments invisible
made it makes me feel scared I'm living
in fear after this the situation is
worse we're being followed it doesn't
sit well with me
Anastasio and his colleagues had raised
concerns about 300,000 so-called ghost
voters on the Electoral Register in Gaza
province before he was shot and his
killers sped off in a car just down the
road they hit an oncoming car and
overturned it was right here
two of the men died at the scene two
others ran away and one was taken to
hospital but bystanders immediately
recognized them and identified them as
members of a special police unit it's
only because of the car crash that in
this case the identity of the killers
was revealed international rights group
Human Rights Watch has documented 14
cases in the last five years where
activists and officials from government
and political parties have been killed
or attacked in similar ways the
attackers normally disappear the
question is no longer whether there are
death squads or not I think was on the
state and on the security was to provide
an answer on why members of the security
forces are going around the country
killing civilians
Anastasio is killing wasn't the only
violence during election campaigns
opposition parties say their rallies
were stopped in some areas by ruling
party supporters and police after the
murder police suspended two senior
officers they told us they're still
investigating and that there's no
evidence of political involvement in the
killings oxidation gas ovens Assange
what's being said by some organizations
and journalists is entirely their own
responsibility
the police therefore doesn't agree with
these statements that go beyond the
police duties the Electoral Commission
says it's run a free and fair poll that
since Tuesday's voting opposition and
some observers have complained of
serious irregularities in the vote
counting process the killing of
Anastasio will certainly affect how safe
people feel to speak out Malcolm Webb al
Jazeera Gaza province Mozambique